all right last month biden nominated
rupali desai a radical arizona-based
lawyer to the ninth circuit court of
appeals
so who exactly is she
you argued that it would be a problem to
extend
an exemption
on the grounds of
religious freedom uh to a particular
small business you've been very active
in an organization that fights against
school choice in arizona you chose an
area of the law
that really requires you to wear a
jersey you clearly do have a
a liberal world view
well liberal world view that's an
understatement as first reported by fox
digital desai serves on the board of
just communities arizona it's a group
whose mission it is to create a world
free of prisons and punishment
so how do you seriously consider having
someone on the bench who doesn't seem to
believe in our criminal justice system
that's wild even for the ninth circuit
she also worked as an attorney for
planned parenthood and helped launch the
state's recreational marijuana program
she's a real gem here now is mike davis
president of the article 3 project
former chief counsel for nominations of
the senate judiciary committee mike
great to see you in studio why is this
nomination of the court of appeals so
bad and how why does it have to be
stopped this one is particularly bad out
of all the bite nominees she's right up
there with one of the worst she's worked
with george soros the aclu planned
parenthood open borders group la raza
the teachers unions she's advocated for
abolishing prisons defunding the police
masked mandates in schools crt in
schools
she's she's a left-wing radical well the
the criminal justice
issue
that in and of itself seems to be a
disqualifier she doesn't believe in
prisons and she doesn't believe in
punishment how do you sit as a federal
appellate court judge if you don't
believe in either of those things well
you you don't and she also thinks that
our criminal justice system is racist
and so she she's gonna have a hard time
doing her job now instead of pressing uh
desai on any one of those issues that we
talked about
here's how secretary uh senator excuse
me corey booker used his time during the
confirmation hearing watch
you can rest because
i just want to talk to you a few minutes
i do not have questions i just want to
tell you both how grateful i am that
you're here
how grateful i am to the president for
nominating you
i think
we are
privileged to have you before us you're
both competent jurists
you both have demonstrated yourself to
be truly qualified
mike spartacus had a lot of questions
there there's just no over there's no
there's no concern at all for oversight
qualification but this is what got them
in trouble with kamala harris and now
they're putting we're trying to put this
other woman on the ninth circuit
and it's going to run into other
problems do you think someone like a joe
manchin would support this well what's
surprising is these two arizona senators
who are supporting this nominee as an
arizona base seat kirsten cinema and
mark kelly are supposed to be moderates
yeah and they're they're far from
moderates when it comes to throwaway
votes they pretend they're moderates but
when it comes to lifetime appointments
on the critically important federal
courts of appeals they they vote in
lockstep with all these radical numbers
so for blake masters who's running you
know probably be the nominee to go up
against kelly that's this is a
major issue in the campaign or it should
be it is i mean this is this nominee ex
serves on a board where they mourns the
execution of a man who kidnapped raped
and murdered an eight-year-old
in september 2021 she argued against a
provision that would ban mass mandates
in schools saying that children will
suffer if that provision becomes law a
great many children in arizona she said
will get coveted they will get
long-covered they will be hospitalized
and they will die she said that is not
hyperbole
mike obviously she was completely wrong
but she was scaring people yeah i mean
she does not have the judgment to be on
the ninth circuit and uh this the two
arizona based senators kirsten cinema
mark kelly dude have made a very bad
decision here by advocating for this
this is why i say that the idea of a
moderate democrat is a unicorn i mean
occasionally
mansion will do the right thing thank
goodness and occasionally cinema will as
well but when it comes to these
these types of radical you know appoint
their they run for the hills they these
democrats vote 100 of their time for
these radical biden nominees oh we've
got to put pressure on the others
including mansion mike thank you very
much thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else